Film Courage: You've brought several DVDs here and they
all have amazing covers. You were telling
us off-camera that some of them are
actually the same films but then
during the distribution phase,
they change titles and covers? Brian Avenet-Bradley, Filmmaker: Yes, okay
well basically what happens is when you
get your foreign sales agent or foreign
distributor who basically sells it to
the other countries they get all the
artwork that you have to redo whatever
cover they want and they can retitle it
to whatever title they want lots of
times they'll add their own artwork like
for example this film is DARK REMAINS.
This was kind of similar to the American
cover but they changed it a little bit
and then in in Canada and Canada
yeah biggest possession in Canada they
really change it you say well okay we
want a blue when a blue look and it's
underrated which is funny because it's
the same version as the radiant version
but I guess they didn't rewrite it in
Canada is the Unrated version so that
was their take on it but still using the
same basic poster art but then when it
got to Japan they really loved the
prison that was in the film so they
decided to go with GHOST PRISON in the
editor prison that actually isn't the
prison in the movie and then they used
this person from clip art who's not in
the movie at all but there is a ghost
kind of like her in the movie but they
decided they wanted this look for the
Asian markets as more of an Asian
actress so they went that way so he just
made change and then of course I'll
actually love this one a lot Australia
they decided to focus on this there's a
ghost girl character in the movie and
they decided to like make the focus more
on her so they totally changed the art
and put the other ghost kind of around
her but that was a really I thought
creative you know Jade but it's all the
same movies so it's kind of funny then
you know sometimes they'll change the
title like ghost of the needle became in
Spain it became ASPHYXIA and what's
funny is they actually got to use that
was supposed to be the cover in the US
for the movie but they they decided they
couldn't use
because they had to get it rated back
then and the ratings board would not
allow this image to be used for an R
rating and we had to deliver in our
rating or the other distributor wanted
us to so so I actually got our original
artwork to change the title of Styx here
but I love this title it's a great title
and in other countries it was called
dead still so just it just changes
depending on what they think they can
sell in that in that marketplace and
that's so that's five different versions
of the same movie
well the two different ones is darker
mains and is what it was ghost the
needle ah and then this other one which
I did bring was called FREEZER most of
the countries caught it freezer with
apostrophe E-R because it's "freeze-her"
and they this image kind of stayed the
same in most of the countries but in the
US it got released differently they
decided to call it COLD BLOOD because
they thought they were worried that
freezer sounded too comedic because it
was like therefore that freeze - her
would make it feel more like a it's a
black comedy but it's very subtle dark
comedy so I think that's one of the
reasons they wanted to change it so so
yeah and then this cover changed we had
a totally different VOD cover and then
the DVD they wanted to make it look more
like a mm slasher risk I guess because
we put some gore in and an environment
that's not in the movie and clipart in
the back which doesn't really represent
the movie well and that's one of the
challenges is you know distributors are
always like well we want to come in
image that makes people get the movie
but the trick of it is you also you want
an image to grab people so it's good to
give other people's advice on what can
market and so the movie but what's
important is you want the image to
attract the people who are gonna like
the movie because you want to be able to
sell what you're really selling and in
trouble can right give what you can run
into with the cover is they can make a
cover where they're selling to a
different sub genre of horror and maybe
those subtitle fans won't be happy with
the movie cuz it's a different movie but
the people who
really like that movie and in a
difference of genre for we'll check it
out because of the cover so you kind of
can get yourself in within this like
trap so it's tricky when dealing with
distributors you always want to get one
that will work with you in terms of the
cover art or at least involve you in it
but it's very difficult of course for
you to ever get final say on it but it's
always good to try to make it part of
the process that you can be involved in
it so you can try to keep it on track to
what you think represents the movie for
what it is
you